ومع تواصل الاحتجاجات في ايران برزت اسماء
ضحايا قمع النظام مساء اميني اول ضحايا
الاحتجاجات الحاليه ولكنها ليست الاخيره
حيث تكررت ماسته اميني مره ثانيه ولكن
باسماء مختلفه ابرزها نغني عبد المالكي
الطالبه التي تعرضت لضرب مبرح بالحراوات
على الراس من قبل قوات الامن ما تسبب لها
بنزيف داخلي ادى الى وفاتها تكرر المشهد
مره اخرى مع الطالبه اسرى بناهي ذات ال 15
ربيعا والتي هاجمتها قوه الامن في مدرسه
شمال غرب ايران ضمن مجموعه من الطالبات
المتظاهرات لينتهي الامر بمقتلها سبقتها
نكيا شرق رامي ذات السته عشر عاما نكيا
فقدت او فقدت في طهران في 20 من سبتمبر
بعد ان اخبر صديقه لها ان الشرطه تطاردها
ليتبين انها كانت بين الحركه الدوليه
الايرانيه وتنتهي حياتها في ظروف غامضه
ويعفر بعد ذلك على جثتها ملقا في الطريق
الهراوات ذاتها قتلت سارينا المراهقه
والتي كانت تنشط على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي الروايه الحكوميه ذاتها تتكرر
وتنكر اي تورط لسلطات في مقتل الفتيات
المراهقات مدعيه انهن انتحرنا او قتلنا في
ظروف غير معروفه تلك كانت اسماء بعض من
رحع ضحيه قمع النظام لكن ارقام الضحايا
اكثر بكثير فقد تجاوزت 460 شخصا حسب منظمه
حقوقيه
[موسيقى]